you're on your own and democrat-run
cities liberal leaders who handcuff
police and let crime run wild are now
encouraging citizens to hire private
security to stay safe a group of New
York store owners taking matters into
their own hands by hiring guards to keep
order in a busy shopping area and mayor
Eric Adams praising the strategy
oh it is a why strategy because I say
this over and over again not only must
the numbers reflect safety but people
must feel safe people must feel safe and
we must make sure that businesses are
safe in the city and that's what the
NYPD is doing this isn't the first time
they're plenty of business owners who
had no choice but to hire private
security you may remember when I
interviewed an armed guard hired by our
Philly gas station right there look at
them that AR judge
if you're the mayor you probably want to
say something like we don't want store
owners to have to hire Farm security
we'd like the NYPD to be able to do
their job or one better as the mayor I
know that you pay taxes and I know that
you work hard to even make you know to
make any money on your business and you
shouldn't have to hire your own security
but the truth is that when you defund
the police to a billion dollars as they
did in New York City and when the rules
are so tough the police are feel like
they're going into a war zone with their
hands behind their back then the local
businesses are left to hire their own
Security First they started by locking
down the items right then they started
by putting more cameras in and hiring
more security and then they had security
escorts who were walking people to their
cars because somebody gets shot or
killed outside of a store so now people
are left to their own devices they it
and the owners as well so the stores are
suffering they're not getting their tax
money's worth and there's an increase in
violence as the theft goes up so this is
when people say I want to have a gun
yeah it's hard to come back from covet
or a crime wave when you look like a
third world country when you have armed
guards standing outside certain shops
certain shops can't afford this though
absolutely well that's what I was
thinking that it probably is a luxury
that this store owner or the Philly gas
station was making enough that they
could afford this these people who need
to make a living and and rightly so
um so the answer isn't like good job on
you the answer is I'm focused on making
sure that New York City or Philadelphia
wherever you're in charge of is a city
where you don't feel like the police are
good enough or can get there in enough
time to help you save your business from
whatever theft is going on
um so yeah I thought it was
a very poor answer or at least not a
Solutions oriented answer
and with the number of people who are
not retiring from the police force early
or not going into it necessarily because
it is such a bad climate for police
officers a lot of them are going into
private security that that's another
option now you take your retirement and
you go and maybe you can make more your
pension certainly it wouldn't be the
same but this is where people where
we're headed if these things aren't
dealt with and then when you try to hire
more cops and train them antifa hides in
the trees and shoots them in the belly
yep and also so the mayor never talks
about the prosecution or the lack of
prosecution and we've talked about this
on the show judges explained it very
well if you're a police officer and you
know that you're gonna get those guys
that beat up Adam klotz our weatherman
on the subway and you know that the next
morning the prosecutor is going to let
them go then you think why do I do this
job why am I here and people feel
demoralized and also just to get do you
know on the closing of the shops there's
a drugstore in I believe it's in Queens
that is now it used to be 24 7. now it's
only going to be open from 11 to 11 20
every day so that people can pick up
their medicines but that's the only
thing that you're allowed to do okay so
that's happening in communities and also
just to get really political if you
think about Biden was saying about the
Republicans on the economy if I were a
republican all I would say all day long
is what a world they defund the police
and expect you to pay for private
security that's the world that the
Democrats want and just repeat it a
hundred times even though they'll say we
don't really believe that but if that's
the way that they're going to play on
the economy just do that on crime that's
a good idea Brian uh Private Security in
New Orleans they might not they were
thinking about not having Mardi Gras
because uh there's so few cops uh and
they don't know if they can do it so now
they everyone's hiring their own
including the professional sports teams
I know someone in New Orleans on a daily
basis certain amount of time a certain
time of night you just don't get gas if
you don't have your car filled up you
can't do it it's too dangerous uh if for
this particular story these guys are
getting 18 an hour they're called Patrol
ambassadors but as Curtis sleetwood
texted me when we were doing this story
this morning who knows anything more
about law enforcement than just about
anyone including Eric Adams he says New
York City is 4 000 cops down and the
fact is these ambassadors might be the
best people in the world but they still
have to call 9-1-1 so it's back to the
cops that weren't there to begin with so
that's why this is a this is terrible 56
percent of small retail businesses
experience theft on it fell over last
year and 86 percent say uh the most of
the time the crime leads to violence all
I want to do is open up a deli and I I
gotta wrestle to keep my to be able to
sell my wise potato chips it doesn't
seem like a good scenario
onion and vinegar those are the best
wise they are good very good but I do
have to brush afterwards yeah salt and
vinegar up next that too I was thinking
sweet onion I think vinegar doesn't
sound terrible yeah it sounds pretty
good Pringles much better it's very
pungent you gotta go for sure I want to
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now